[Musik]
in aller Kürze die wichtigsten
Nachrichten in der Handball Halbzeit
schön guten Abend zusammen ja Kanzler
Scholz hat mal wieder alle überrascht
viele Namen wurden gehandelt aber nicht
Boris Pistorius aber genau er
Niedersachsens SPD Innenminister wird
neuer Verteidigungsminister und soll
zügig Zeitenwende und den Zustand der
bundeswehrmanagement wenig überraschend
überwiegend Lob aus den ampelparteien
die Union äußerte sich zurückhaltend
über den neuen die Reaktionen und
Perspektiven Andreas Huppert
Boris Pistorius so heißt also der
künftige Oberbefehlshaber der Bundeswehr
überraschend wird er Deutschlands neuer
Verteidigungsminister von da bin ich mir
der Verantwortung der großen Bedeutung
dieser Aufgabe natürlich sehr bewusst
und bin umso dankbarer dass sie mir
zugetraut wird und werde mich vom ersten
Tag an mit 150 Prozent in dieser Aufgabe
reinstürzen Durchsetzung stark ein
Macher der zuhören kann so beschreiben
in Parteifreunde und jene die mit ihm
gearbeitet haben genau der richtige Mann
auf einem der wichtigsten
Regierungsposten so der Bundeskanzler
ich bin immer erzeugt dass das jemand
ist der mit der Truppe kann und den die
Soldaten und Soldaten sehr mögen werden
und ich bin sehr dankbar dass er ja
gesagt hat und wir freuen uns auf die
gute Zusammenarbeit mit dem Minister
Boris Pistorius schon des öfteren wurde
Pistorius für die Bundespolitik
gehandelt z.B als Innenminister immer
kam ihm dann SPD intern die Quote in die
Quere zu viele Niedersachsen zu viele
Männer apropos Quote die Grünen Zweifels
zwar nicht an den Fähigkeiten Pistorius
als Verteidigungsminister allerdings
sehen Sie mit der Entscheidung das
Prinzip der Parität im Kabinett also die
gleiche Anzahl Frauen und Männer
verletzt für uns Grüne ist das weiterhin
Selbstverständnis und auch
selbstverständlich dass wir die Hälfte
an Frauen mindestens in Führungsposition
haben die CDU Opposition stört eher das
Pistorius bislang keine politische
Erfahrung in Sachen Bundeswehr vorweisen
kann wir wünschen ihm Erfolg bei der
Ausübung dieses wichtigen Amtes es ist
in der gegenwärtigen Lage mit Krieg in
Europa vielleicht das wichtigste Amt das
in der
Bundesregierung nach dem Bundeskanzler
ausgeübt wird vielen Dank Boris bist
durius am Donnerstag wird der offiziell
vom Bundespräsidenten ernannt und den
Parlament als Verteidigungsminister
vereidigt
fragen wir Theo call in Berlin ist
Pistorius der absolute Wunschkandidat
und wie viel Risiko schwingt jetzt mit
also dass er der absolute Wunschkandidat
war das ist glaube ich auszuschließen
denn der Kanzler wurde wirklich schon am
dritten januar von Frau Lambrecht über
ihre rücktrittsabsicht informiert
Pistorius aber wurde erst gestern
gefragt dazwischen dürften viele andere
Ideen und Namen ventiliert worden sein
übrigens wurde sogar gehörig
zwischenzeitlich die Überlegung eines
ringtauschs angestellt also dass ein
weiterer männlicher Minister Platz
machen müsste damit die Geschlechter
Parität bestehen bleibt das hat man dann
im Kanzleramt aber verworfen die
Herausforderungen und Risiken für den
neuen könnten natürlich kaum größer sein
gleich am ersten Tag kommt USA
Verteidigungsminister Osten zu Besuch
und es geht dann um die Frage künftiger
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine und
danach wartet neben der schnelleren
Aufrüstung die eigentliche Großbaustelle
nämlich die Umstrukturierung der
Bundeswehr nach einem weitgehend
verzauberten Jahr sollte die Zeiten wenn
die jetzt auch in Deutschland
Verteidigung ankommen danke nach Berlin
Theo Paul
schwierige Mission
tutorius wird Verteidigungsminister
heißt das ZDF Spezial das wir direkt
nach dem Handball bringen gegen 19 Uhr
ja kaum besetzte Olaf Scholz
Deutschlands wohl aktuell wichtigsten
Ministerposten neu geht es weiter zum
Weltwirtschaftsforum nach Davos
abgeschirmt in den Schweizer Bergen
beraten mächtige Menschen aus Politik
Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft wieder über
die Krisen der Zeit wie den Ukraine
Krieg und seine Folgen berichtet
weit weg von den Krisen liegt
abgeschottet das beschauliche Davos doch
sie sind allgegenwärtig die Promenade
wird zum Mittelpunkt der Weltkonzerne
aber ein Gebäude fällt besonders auf das
Haus der Ukraine dort erinnern sie an
die Schrecken des Krieges
sie ist gekommen um darüber zu reden
Olena selenska die Frau des ukrainischen
Präsidenten ist der Stargast mit einer
klaren Botschaft
jeder hat das Recht auf ein Leben in
Freiheit und Frieden deshalb gibt es nur
eine Lösung die russischen Truppen
müssen sich komplett aus der Ukraine
zurückziehen
5000 Soldaten der Schweizer Armee
sichern den Ort ab mehr als 50
Regierungschefs kommen nicht eingeladen
der russische Präsident Putin am Morgen
reden sie aber schon über ihn es geht um
Kampfpanzer für die Ukraine der deutsche
Bundeskanzler sperrt sich bis jetzt
dagegen anderen Europa machen immer mehr
drucken jemand muss die politische
Führung übernehmen damit die Ukraine
unterstützt wird denn die Kampfpanzer
spielen eine entscheidende strategische
Rolle glauben sie Bundeskanzler Scholz
übernimmt die Führung
ich gehe fest davon aus dass er eine
Entscheidung trifft
Bundeskanzler Scholz kommt morgen nach
Davos hier wächst der Druck für ihn
Antworten mitzubringen
der Solidaritätszuschlag ist ja für die
meisten Geschichte nur noch sehr gut
verdienende müssen in Zahlen das sei
eine ungleiche Behandlung argumentieren
Kläger in einem Prozess vor dem
Bundesfinanzhof der heute begonnen hat
außerdem sei der ursprüngliche Zweck
nämlich dem Osten zu helfen entfallen
eine Entscheidung soll Ende des Monats
verkündet werden
zum ersten Mal seit mehr als 60 Jahren
ist in China die Bevölkerungszahl
zurückgegangen ende Dezember waren 1,41
Milliarden Einwohner gemeldet das sind
rund 850.000 weniger als ein Jahr zuvor
schon länger verzeichnet China deutlich
weniger Geburten bei gleichzeitiger
Überalterung der Gesellschaft und das
obwohl die ein Kind Politik schon vor
acht Jahren abgeschafft worden war
der Prozess um den Juwelen Diebstahl im
Grünen Gewölbe in Dresden da gab es
heute mehrere Geständnisse drei der
sechs Angeklagten sagten umfassend aus
dies war Teil einer Absprache um mildere
Strafen zu bekommen dazu gehörte auch
die Rückgabe eines Großteils der Beute
bei dem Einbruch 2019 waren
Schmuckstücke im Wert von mehr als 113
Millionen Euro gestohlen worden
so das Wetter das gibt's gleich noch
zwei Hinweise das heute journal um 22
Uhr mit Maria das lomka und ein ZDF
Spezial zum neuen Verteidigungsminister
direkt nach dem Handball gegen 19:40 Uhr
und jetzt weiterhin viel Spaß mit der
zweiten Halbzeit
[Musik]
hallo das Wetter heute Nacht ist drei
geteilt an der Nordseeküste gibt es
einige Schneeschauer zwischen der
Ostseeküste und der Mosel ist der Himmel
zum Teil auch klar Richtung Süden und
südostenfeld Schnee das können durchaus
einige Zentimeter sein machen Sie sich
auf rutschige Straßen gefasst denn die
Temperaturen sinken doch eigentlich
überall in den Frost besonders eisig
wird hier im Rothaargebirge mit minus 9
Grad die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen -1 + 4 Grad und die
Wetter 3 Teilung bleibt uns erhalten in
Schleswig-Holstein gibt's morgen Schnee
Regenschauer und zwischen Rügen und der
Eifel zeigt sich auch häufiger mal die
Sonne Richtung Süden und südostenfeld
weiterhin Schnee und winterlich geht's
auch in den nächsten Tagen weiter bei -3
des plus fünf Grad tschüss